[Music]  of course as I mentioned last night Tim  Tebow he did it again Tebow led the  Denver Broncos to a dramatic victory  over the Pittsburgh Steelers in overtime  now it was an amazing final play and I  really wanted to show it to you tonight  and talk about it but if I did show it  the NFL would charge me thousands and  thousands of dollars okay it's really  expensive I thought we got to do  something so we were able to recreate  the thrilling final moments with the  help once again of our Conan peanut  players with the game tied at 23 Denver  quarterback Tim Tebow took the snap and  flipped a hand off the realistic 80  before miraculously finding  wide-receiver Demaryius Thomas open at  the 40-yard line gosh raced into the end  zone to give the victory to them as the  crowd went wild  the devoutly religious Tebow went  to give thanks for his Bigfoot  [Applause]  Denver goes on to play New England on  Saturday while the Pittsburgh Steelers  go straight to hell  [Applause]  you